pas grave elle est sublime et c'est la
plus belle du monde
oui c'est une gueule avant une des
colonnes joli mais moi franchement pour
vous ça fait le lui dis en lorraine mais
là je suis complètement social de
travaux
elles font quoi les faire un bisou sur
la bouche à doha mais pas ici bas alors
maintenant mais si c'est chez vous
qu'est ce qu'on en a à [ __ ]
[Applaudissements]
on a envie de qui fait quoi peut on est
bientôt là voilà c'est bientôt la fin de
la semaine
on est tous fatigués on a tous des
soucis on en a tous fait la tête on n'a
plus tous en vie
voilà vous n'êtes pas malade mais pas de
nom on est pas mal
je me propose de te ramener après une
mission là-bas mais n'a pas de ramener à
part ça travaille tellement ici
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]